[Musique]
moi je pense que la france n'a pas en
réalité à se soucier d'individus qui ont
renié leur nationalité brûler leurs
passeports brûlé leur carte d'identité
qui ont tué nos enfants au bataclan dans
les rues de paris à nice à magnanville à
lyon à marseille et qui ont participé à
une entreprise de type génocidaires au
moyen-orient fin moment donné faut aussi
être très claire alors comme vous l'avez
dit on en a déjà récupéré un certain
nombre depuis 2000 12 215 et il faut
savoir qu'aujourd'hui 62 sont libres
sont des chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur
donc lorsque emmanuel macron nous dit
qu'ils sont tous emprisonnés et
judiciariser c'est faux aujourd'hui il
faut savoir qu'à des djihadistes qui
sont revenus en france et qui sont
libres je pars du principe que tu vas tu
auriez qu'est-ce qu'ils soient
transférés en irak ils soient transférés
en irak qu'ils soient jugés
là où ils ont commis leur un parti qui
ne respecteraient pas la laïcité la
souveraineté nationale c'est à dire qui
ne privilégie pas une communauté par
rapport à aux autres c'est un parti
communautariste considérons qu'au dessus
de toutes les minorités
il existe la majorité et qu'il existe au
dessus des communautés la communauté
nationale la majorité est contestée par
les minorités c'est un fait eh bien
faisons attention à ce que notre pays ne
sombre pas dans la tyrannie des
minorités je pense que la présidence des
mails macron est une présidence bavarde
et anxiogène bavarde parce que beaucoup
de mots beaucoup de paroles mais des
actes très faible pas de réformes
véritables anxiogène parce que prenez
l'exemple de la retraite on dit tout et
n'importe quoi
chaque français se pensent menacé le
président lui-même au mois d'août a fait
la liste des perdants
il a cité les enseignants le personnel
soignant donc c'est anxiogène parce que
quand on n'est pas clair avec les
français quand on dit pas où on veut
aller
je pense que ont créé beaucoup beaucoup
d'angoissé ce qui est en train de se
passer
chaque français se dit qu'est ce qui va
nous tomber sur la tête il fait semblant
de faire des réformes
il met des coups d'épée dans l'eau il
cristallise les colères il irrite les
uns et les autres je pense qu'il a
profondément fracturé le pays est
aujourd'hui nous en sommes là mais je me
pose une question plus fondamentale au
fond quel est le lien qui emmanuel
macron a avec le pays
c'est une question que nous nous posons
depuis le début ces coups de menton
cette forme d'arrogance pour moi pèse
beaucoup aujourd'hui dans la
fracturation au delà des
l'intention de réformes qui peuvent être
annoncées ici ou là
[Musique]